doc did i give you the wrong number i'm
the worst of course you did
of course i did i'm only trying to run
the world here doc i can't really
babysit
everybody i mean wouldn't you think good
job running the world
oh dog i'm trying how are you today i
would disagree with that but other than
that you're doing a good job running the
world i'm doing great
listen i'm talking to you after a win we
could have lost in this conversation
when it's gone as well
by the way don't joke i i watched last
night i'm thinking myself
don't be the bad juju don't do it you
know
tell me what is working there i was
saying to the guys i was showing off
that i was on the phone with you when we
were talking about whether you're gonna
go there or not
what's working there in philadelphia
right now you know we have
a group of guys that are bought in to a
way of playing
and um you know
they they needed that they just needed
uh that direction they needed to
um you know they're young i think that's
what you know i keep hearing like ben
and joelle ben and joelle
have not won and when we had our first
talk i asked him could they put yet
at the end of that sentence and it
changes the way you think about it
you know when you just keep saying we
haven't won that makes it a very
negative thing
uh and i said the whole league hasn't
won
uh if you go through each guy but
when you have bigger dreams yet is the
most important part of that
and they haven't won yet and you can see
them trying to figure it out
every night and they're doing it but
what is it
because in the past it was clear that
they were a little bit like oil and
water so what is it that you did besides
put the word yet into a sentence that
made them play this way
they have to understand that they do fit
when you hear every day that you don't
fit
then you start looking for the reasons
why you don't fit
uh and my job was to come in here and
show them how well they fit together
how both of them are phenomenal
defenders and if we have one at the
front of our defense and one at the back
of our defense
we can become a like a great defensive
team
how you know they keep talking about
room and i said you guys don't need room
i said ben every time you drive
you want joelle to be on the other block
and he said well there's no room i said
no there's not
it's better no one's going to leave joel
you know who's going to leave joellenby
to go block your shot
who's going to help with joel yeah i
said that's a duncan assist
you guys have you actually create more
room for each other not less
and so that's you know our first couple
of weeks that's all we did we talked
about it we showed it on film and
and uh the other thing we gave about a
band uh to be our point guard
and you know he loves the role um
and the last thing i guess the two
things with joel go to the post
be a dominant big and you are you can
score everywhere else we know that
but you don't have to show us that show
us how great you are on the post
and with ben uh having the ball in his
hands and
not worrying about shooting just worried
about creating threes and ben leads the
league this year
in creating threes you know and no one's
talking about him shooting him anymore
they're talking about how many he's
creating
but they are talking about but sorry doc
but they are talking about
his defense and he forces luka doncic to
seven turnovers last night so yeah
he's the he is at his position
you know kawhi maybe two others they're
all in the same group but
then it's rare that i don't think i've
ever
said this in this way but ben has the
ability to literally swallow
his offensive player he's just so big
strong and long
uh and so agile that he he just
he has an amazing ability defensively
and
you know that was the first thing i told
him like i get the offense the offensive
offense but you should be the best
defensive player in the league
and he's taking heat to that and he's
doing it so
so far so good you know we're gonna have
a lot of tests in front of us
um but the team uh we fit
and that's important how different is it
for you
with these two young guys comparatively
with what you were working with last
year in los angeles with kawhi leonard
and paul george
well it's different in the fact that
last year i really never worked with him
you know uh unfortunately pg
miss the entire training camp um
so did kawhi for the most part i think
kawaii played one preseason game
uh pg missed the first 14 games of the
year
came back for five and then he got
injured again
so i think one of our coaches told me
we actually practiced with pg and kawhi
on the floor last year
four times for the season you know and
so i really never
got that but they were veterans so it is
a difference like young guys they're
still at a point
of trying to figure out how they can win
and how they can be great
where you know pg and especially kawhi
you know christ
two-time three-time champion uh champ
finals mvp a couple times
you know he's he was more just trying to
figure out how he can win with this team
he didn't need to be taught how to do
anything
really so i would say that's the biggest
difference dog rivers here on the rich
eisens show susie shuster in for rich
eisen
when we spoke i think it could have been
the day that you took that job you said
you were the most intrigued and you had
so many other offers out there
what was it about this job that made you
say i'm going to pick up
and i'm going to move across the country
and i'm going to set my roots down in
philadelphia
it was the only job as you know i mean i
had the other job offers
but as you knew talking to you um i was
going to take that job
where i was going to do the rich eisen
show that's true yeah
with me where was that you know and the
only reason i took that job is number
one
uh those two guys uh their youth
and knowing that they had such a high
ceiling left
uh tobias harris who i've known forever
uh and coached and then elton brand
and the ownership group but more elton
brand because that's who i knew
uh and had a relationship with um and
the way they were gonna structure it for
me and allow me to do the things that i
thought the organization needed to
change the culture
um and they gave me a green light on
everything uh
was the reason one last question for doc
rivers who joins us here on the rich
eisen show doc we
we are talking a lot about kyrie irving
putting kobe bryant's name out there as
the logo what are your thoughts on
possibly replacing jerry west with kobe
bryant
you know i've been asked that and i
don't know the answer to that i mean
uh michael jordan would be the logo i
mean listen if you want a logo
michael to me would be it um
but i don't know if you change for
change you know
um you usually change things
because of history and you find
something out
that doesn't fit jerry has been a
deserving logo and i have no problem
with him continually
being the logo um i mean what are we
going to do change the logo every 10
years or 20 years
so i like our logo i think we should
actually stick with it i'm probably in
the minority
uh in that thought this has nothing to
do with cancel culture which
uh something i can't stand anyone saying
um
because you know it's it's funny when
you think about
that we're trying to change our careers
right uh every company
wants to change the culture of their
companies and yet
when we try to change it in this country
it's a bad thing
uh yeah so well you know how i feel
about that but that's a whole different
conversation that's a whole different
conversation that's why i stopped
as always is a smart thing to do doc
thank you for taking the time as always
and
thanks for coming by the show and i'm
sure you and i will be in touch soon but
good luck for the rest of the season
and i'm the first guy to call you on the
house phone thank you
that's exactly right and let's keep it
that way please doc rivers
taking time to drop by hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here